11 years of work and then you know this
is it this is
this is the mothership where
everything happens
barely a month to go a NASA Arcata has a
World Cup to deliver
one more protested against then often
celebrated with the suffering of Migrant
workers a growing concern for teams
Bound for Qatar
do you have a message for the English
and Welsh FAS who are concerned about
the implementation of this worker
compensation fund people don't
understand the amount of work that's
gone over gone in over the past 10 years
in terms of really really overhauling
um the workers rights and the workers
laws in this country so when people come
out and say yes we know we agree that
there needs to be some sort of
compensation fund so they're just taking
they're just you know reading off a
piece of paper are you fine with Gareth
Bale and Harry Kane wearing those
rainbow colored one Lavan band there's a
lot of things that we read in the Press
about armbands that are going to be warm
we don't know anything that's confirmed
or anything that's official there has
been some confusion could you clear that
up can fans come with rainbow Flags
look we've always said that everybody's
welcome here all we ask is for people to
be respectful of the culture what would
your message those fans be who are sort
of wary of maybe coming those lgbtq plus
fans everybody is welcome here and
everybody will feel safe when they come
to Qatar would that include say
everybody gay friends if they were
holding hands in public would that be
okay yes
that's a message of reassurance to them
yes
so they could show some form of if I
held your hand Rob why not and I walked
outside the street for hours and hours
and hours nobody would say anything to
us do you thinking somewhere that Qatar
was being unfairly scrutinized being the
first Middle East World Cup in
particular yeah I think a lot of it has
to do with that it's got our worthy of
hosting a World Cup will Qatar ever be
ready to host the World Cup do you feel
some of that criticism might evade into
racism
laughs
I'm not going to get into uh
um what the intentions are of other
people I'm not going to get into the
minds and Souls of other people but you
know who knows possibly
reassurance is happy and offered
botanese persists of discriminatory laws
and worker abuses as Qatar prepares to
welcome the world
Rob Harris Sky News Doha